[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce sens public votre rendez-vous
quotidien de débat et de reportage sur
Public Sénat 90 minutes pour donner du
sens à l'actualité grâce à nos invités
experts et voici le sommaire de ce 6
juillet Marlène Schiappa épinglé par la
commission d'enquête du Sénat pour sa
gestion calamiteuse du fond Marianne se
font mis en place après l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty pour combattre les discours
séparatistes le rapporteur parle d'un
coup politique qui a dérapé en lisant le
rapport vous constaterez qu'à toutes les
étapes de ce projet le manque de rigueur
l'opacité et je le dis la désinvolture
on conduit au fiasco
quel avenir pour Marlène Schiappa
peut-il y avoir des conséquences
judiciaires pour la ministre ou pour
Mohammed Sifaoui l'un des bénéficiaires
controversés du fond Marianne on en
débat juste après ces titres et puis
dans 45 minutes c'est un autre débat
d'actualité que je vous propose après le
vote ce mercredi soir de la loi pour
sécuriser l'espace numérique
cyber-harcèlement accès des enfants au
site porno usurpation d'identité sur
Internet incitation à la violence lors
des émeutes les réseaux sociaux et les
plateformes sont trop souvent des
espaces de non-droits on verra comment
la France et l'Europe veulent reprendre
la main mais d'abord donc les
conclusions de la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale sur le fond Marianne elles
tiennent en un mot accablant Samya de
chir ça vient Recker Quentin Calmet
dérive d'un coup politique opération de
communication les sénateurs n'ont pas de
mots assez durs pour qualifier l'échec
du fond Marianne le manque de rigueur
l'opacité et je le dis la désinvolture
on conduit au fiasco adopter à la quasi
unanimité le rapport de la commission
d'enquête accablant pour Marlène
Schiappa en avril dernier 6 mois après
l'assassinat de Samuel Patty celle qui
est alors ministre en charge de la
citoyenneté lance un fond pour lutter
contre les discours séparatistes
2,5 millions d'euros attribués à 17
associations comment ont-elles été
choisie la commission d'enquête dénonce
la maturisme d'un processus de sélection
opaque ou la ministre serait
personnellement intervenu sans laisser
aucune trace écrite justifiant ses choix
initialement sélectionné pour recevoir
100.000 euros SOS Racisme a finalement
été écartée du fond Marianne dans le cas
de SOS Racisme la ministre est intervenu
pour revenir sur une décision du comité
de sélection un mail daté du 1er juin
indique que la décision d'exclure cette
association a bien été prise lors d'une
réunion avec la ministre les sénateurs
reprochent aussi à Marlène Schiappa
d'avoir sélectionné une association
avant même la création du fond l'Union
des sociétés d'éducation physique et de
préparation militaire pour 355000 euros
l'uspm codirigé par Mohamed cifaoui
n'aurait produit que quelques vidéos en
ligne sans que personne ne s'en est meuf
car une fois sélectionné les
associations n'auraient fait l'objet
d'aucun suivi pour contrôler leur action
s'étonne la commission d'enquête
senatoriale les échecs du fond Marianne
sont tout autant le résultat du des
investissements
du manque d'intérêt ou du désintérêt du
pouvoir politique
dès après la sélection des projets
est-ce un déni de responsabilité après
son lancement à l'exception d'une
réunion de décembre 2021 on ne peut
distinguer aucun signe d'une véritable
implication politique
quant à la mise en oeuvre de ce fond
Marianne la promesse qui avait été faite
solennellement devant les Français
à la suite d'un événement tragique n'a
pas été tenu
ce qui relève pleinement de la
responsabilité politique de la ministre
lors de son audition devant les
sénateurs Marlène Schiappa annie est
tout implication personnelle et ses
défaussée sur son administration un
témoignage contradictoire avec celui
d'autres acteurs entendus la commission
d'enquête a communiqué ses conclusions
au parquet national financier qui a déjà
ouvert une information judiciaire sur le
sujet
et pour débattre des conclusions de
cette commission de ces conséquences
politiques pourquoi pas judiciaire on
verra j'accueil Claude Raynal bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénateur socialiste
de la Haute-Garonne président la
commission des finances et on vous a vu
dans notre reportage président de la
mission d'information fond Marianne qui
a obtenu ensuite ses prérogatives de
commission d'enquête Hélène Salvi
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
journaliste Mediapart responsable du
pôle politique Jacques Jean garrigue
bonsoir bienvenue à vous historien
président du Comité d'histoire
parlementaire et auteur de ce livre
Élisée contre Matignon le couple
infernal de 1958 à nos jours qui est
publié chez Talandier Laetitia cru pas
bonsoir Laetitia bienvenue éditorialiste
politique et heureux de vous retrouver
sur sur ce plateau allez un premier tour
de table Claude rénale qu'est-ce qui
vous frappe le plus dans ce dossier le
manque de de rigueur l'opacité quelles
sont les mots qui vous viennent
spontanément
et peut-être deux choses la première
c'est
que face à un certain nombre
d'information qui avait été fourni par
la presse il y a d'abord eu une position
qui n'était pas une position de
responsabilité de l'administration
charge et je pense que s'il y avait eu
tout de suite quelques mots d'apaisement
autour de l'idée je suis responsable de
sephor et de tout ce qui se déroule et
je demande je confirme la position de la
ministre bacaisse pour ouvrir une
enquête de l'igéa mais ce qui lui a
succédé je pense que déjà vous voyez on
serait descendu d'un taux voilà mais
malheureusement le choix qui a été fait
ça a été le choix du déni
on parle pas de responsabilité la seule
moment où on en parle c'est dans
l'audition lorsque je la lance sur ce
sujet parce que juste avant pendant 20
minutes elle nous explique beaucoup de
choses intéressantes mais elle ne parle
pas de responsabilité il a fallu que je
la lance là-dessus donc ça c'est
extrêmement surprenant
et pour
des élus qui avant l'habitude de d'être
en pleine responsabilité sur nos
territoires dans nos responsabilités de
direction c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement choquant que de pas
démarrer en disant bah écoutez il se
peut qu'il y a un problème en tout cas
si j'assume la responsabilité et ensuite
on voit
Hélène Salvi il y a une sorte de
complémentarité entre le travail des des
journalistes et le travail d'une
commission d'enquête parlementaire
est-ce que vous avez appris des choses
qu'est-ce que vous avez appris en
assistant ou en regardant ces auditions
il y a effectivement une vraie
complémentarité ce sont évidemment deux
fonctions différentes je trouve que la
commission d'enquête a permis de révéler
des informations grâce aux prérogatives
aussi de cette commission d'enquête
c'est-à-dire que les sénateurs ont accès
à un certain nombre de documents
d'éléments auxquels les journalistes
n'ont pas forcément accès et par
ailleurs l'autre sujet intéressant c'est
que toutes les auditions qui ont été
menées par les sénateurs sont faites
sous serment ce qui crée en fait
beaucoup de
de choses intéressantes à observer
puisque tous et toutes ne disent pas la
même chose et des versions qui
finalement ne se recoupaient pas
finissent par la force finalement du
serment par soulever une forme de vérité
un exemple peut-être de ce que vous avez
appris de ce que la commission d'enquête
a permis de révéler justement grâce à
ses prérogatives alors justement là dans
la complémentarité entre le travail
journalistique et le travail de des
sénateurs par exemple le jour où
Sébastien Jallet qui est donc un haut
fonctionnaire l'ancien directeur de
cabinet a été auditionné il révèle grâce
aux questions des sénateurs il révèle le
fait que oui contrairement à ce qu'elle
répétait depuis le départ Marlène Chapat
et bien intervenu après le comité de
sélection du fond Marianne pour bifer
une association qui avait été choisie en
l'occurrence SOS Racisme pour des
raisons diales à ce moment-là Sébastien
Jallet d'un passif ancien entre la
ministre et le responsable de
à ce moment là Sébastien Jallet parle
d'une association il s'avère que nous ça
recoupe des informations que nous avions
déjà à Mediapart et nous sortons dans la
foulée le fait qu'il s'agit bien de SOS
Racisme Jean Gary qu'est-ce que vous
retenez première question très générale
de je reste sur l'audition de marine
Chapa pour commencer écoutez-leur moi je
voudrais de manière sinigre remercier
Marlène Schiappa d'avoir aussi mal
préparé et lancer cette cette
association parce qu'elle a permis de
révéler à quel point était utile dans
notre vie politique des commissions
d'enquête parlementaires de ce type qui
nous
réhabilite qui réhabilite véritablement
le rôle du Parlement dans notre
République par rapport à ce qu'est
l'intégrité de la République et qui à la
manière dont ça a été mené par cette
nouvelle dream team
USON rénale il y avait la dream team
basse sueur pour la commission
et là il y a une nouvelle dream team je
crois qu'ils ont donné un très très bon
exemple de ce que doivent être des des
hommes politiques responsables dans la
clarté dans la recherche de la
transparence sans être des fous qui est
invisent sans vouloir couper des têtes
c'était pas du tout leur leur intention
et c'est vrai que la vérité puis
finalement c'est c'est imposé on a vu à
quel point cette cette histoire était
relevée plus du coup de communication et
c'est très dommage parce que faire une
mission contre le discours séparatiste
c'est quelque chose de très important
aider des subventionnés des associations
contre ce discours c'est très important
malheureusement ça a été un peu et même
beaucoup gâché par ce coup de com alors
je reste sur les éléments de de
communication en tout cas les mots
choisis par Marlène Schiappa le jour de
son audition qui a duré autour de trois
heures elle donne effectivement peu
d'éléments tangibles c'est ce que nous
dit
cet après-midi le sénateur a l'air de
Meurthe-et-Moselle qui le rapporteur de
cette commission Jean-François Husson
écoutez bien les détails ce que je
relève
s'agissant de la ministre
nous l'avons additionné
avec méthode et patiemment pendant trois
heures
elle est l'occasion de dire qu'elle
assumait toute sa responsabilité
mais je ne l'ai jamais vu rentrer
ou proposer
à notre commission d'enquête
des éléments un peu plus tangibles
elle a beaucoup contourné elle s'est
largement défaussée sur l'administration
le cabinet elle a eu beaucoup
de pertes de mémoire
elle l'a dit elle-même il suffit de
reprendre le script des auditions
il y a certains certaines prises de
parole qui sont
consternante de mon point de vue et
affligeante Hélène Salvi elle a préféré
Marlène Schiappa joue la carte de
l'incompétence plutôt que d'assumer sa
responsabilité est-ce que vous diriez ça
alors je sais pas si elle a joué la
carte de l'incompétence aussi elle a
montré que elle était incompétente à ce
poste le fait est que la commission
d'enquête sénatoriale a révélé à mon
sens un fait éminemment politique qui
est comme l'a dit Monsieur Husson une
ministre qui n'a pas géré son son fond
on parle quand même de 2 millions
d'euros on n'est pas sur de l'argent
public
comme ça je veux dire c'est ça ça reste
ça reste voilà beaucoup d'argent qui a
géré son fond en termes de communication
c'est à dire que elle est partie tambour
battant pour mener cette opération dans
les médias pour la présenter et après
plus personne et la théorie selon
laquelle ce sont l'administration qui
serait défaillante puisque c'est ce
qu'elle apporte sur la table vous n'y
croyez pas c'est c'est unique séparé
d'une personne en fait c'est pas
tellement une théorie c'est c'est que
une ministre a la tutelle sur son
administration c'est pas c'est tous ceux
qui travaillent pour vous sont
incompétents
ministère il y a bien sûr
je peux me permettre sur ce cette
question il y a bien des responsabilités
administratives nous les avons pointé
également il y a des responsabilités
administratives bien entendu et il y a
des responsabilités politiques les
responsabilités administratives on peut
dire qu'il y a concordance entre ce que
nous avons dit depuis le début ce qui
est ressorti des commissions et le
premier rapport qui est sorti par
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration qui qui pointe les
mêmes éléments en réalité et il y a bien
eu des manquements de l'administration
mais si vous voulez
ne pas imaginer un instant que seuls les
manquements de l'administration sont à
l'origine du dysfonctionnement
d'ailleurs Jean Garry il y a le préfet
Christian Gravel qui lui a tiré les
conséquence des des différentes
conclusions démissionnant donc le
contraste entre ce que lui fait et
Marlène Schiappa face à la commission
sénatoriale était assez frappant
effectivement c'est un vrai contraste
mais ça comment dire ça c'est une
vieillissement cette difficulté et c'est
ça le difficulté des politiques depuis
150 ans à assumer leur responsabilité
leurs erreurs leur faute et en
l'occurrence oui il y a eu quand même un
certain nombre de dysfonctionnement
interférences dans le choix des des
associations non suivis des dossiers qui
qui auraient pu conduire au moins à une
responsabilisation on se souvient de la
phrase de Georgina Dufois responsable
mais pas coupable au moins la
responsabilité voilà moi je dirais pas
que là on est en présence d'une affaire
d'état ou même d'un scandale mais mais
on est dans quelque chose qui pointe
amateurisme ou
dans le tueur moi je pense que on va
aller plutôt du côté de la désinvolture
parce que on voit bien que on est en
présence d'une femme politique qui est
qui est quand même très tournée vers
tout ce qui relève de la communication
puisque sans doute du suivi des dossiers
et donc dans ce dis que on aurait
attendu à un moment donné au moins une
sorte de mea culpa alors on a on n'a pas
encore et je pense que c'est intéressant
dans ce débat de de le faire entendu
revu un extrait justement de l'audition
de de Marlène Schiappa vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure ce qui concerne
SOS Racisme c'est un échange d'ailleurs
qui vous concerne directement que Claude
Raynal on va voir comment comment ça se
passe sur effectivement cet argent qui
était prévu et qui a disparu de
subventions qui pouvait être alloués à
l'association SOS Racisme regardez je
n'ai pas supprimé de subventions à SOS
Racisme je ne dis pas que c'est ce que
vous avez dit mais j'ai eu des réponses
qui ont été portées en ce sens disant
que mes décisions auraient mis en péril
un équilibre financier d'une association
je rappelle qu'on est sur un appel à
projet on parle pas de financement ni de
fonctionnement pour les associations
donc je n'enlève pas de l'argent à SOS
racisme dont il bénéficierait chaque
année
alors je vais je vais y revenir mais en
tout cas première élément oui c'est un
peu endroit vous avez raison c'est
subtil comme réponse le je pense que le
droit en porte
avec un peu de recul quelques quelques
semaines de recul qu'est-ce qui vous
frappe dans cet argumentation
c'est incontournement du sujet voilà ça
répond pas au fond faire un distinguo
entre le fait de refuser une subvention
ou de ne pas finalement donner suite à
une façon bon voilà ça ne trompe
personne si vous voulez je voudrais y
revenir d'un point allez-y rien interdit
dans notre système puisqu'il y a un
problème de responsabilité du pouvoir
politique en tout rien n'interdit à une
ministre de changer une sélection
de considérer que SOS Racisme et pas le
plus efficace pour pour contrer le
discours séparatiste pourquoi pas
considérer après
débat après discussions que tel ou tel
association ne mérite pas que peut-être
d'autres exta pourquoi pas les lanceront
mais à ce moment-là elle doit l'écrire
elle doit motiver la décision
c'est ça qu'on doit dans un système qui
est séparé elle doit c'est elle doit
également
et puis de manière générale dans tout ce
qui s'appelle appel à projet ailleurs ou
appel d'offre par exemple et bien nous
un appel d'offres vous devez motiver vos
positions et si vous les motivez pas et
bien c'est suspect ça devient tout de
suite suspect voilà on me dit vous avez
retiré pourquoi alors la raison qui est
donnée est un peu absconne bon elle est
pas tout à fait juste bon voilà on
essaye de trouver un argument mais après
coup dans la réalité le préfet j'allais
à 10 qui s'est passé bon il a dû avoir
une phrase la ministre disant je ne
souhaite pas voilà lui il a attiré la
conclusion qui avait quelque chose
d'historique entre eux très bien voilà
mais la ministre a bon droit pouvait
éventuellement le faire mais
en motivant et éventuellement en
écrivant à l'association disant elle
n'est pas retenue et éventuellement en
motivant la raison voilà mais sur le
faire comme ça en disant c'est moi qui
décide ça c'est pas possible c'est quand
même le moment puis on va on va
approfondir la com de Marlène chappa
dans un instant Laetitia mais c'est
quand même le moment elle a une sa vie
où
on a quand même deux vérités enfin vous
dites les vérites la vérité a fini par
par émerger là on a deux versions qui
sont contradictoires quand même d'un
même fait oui entre la ministre et son
ancien directeur de cabinet certes le
problème c'est que quand Marlène
Schiappa dit il y a une mauvaise
interprétation parce que y compris sur
ce sujet elle s'est défaussée sur son
ancien directeur de cabinet en disant il
a certainement mal compris ce que
j'avais voulu signifier bon pourquoi pas
c'est c'est sa version des faits le fait
est que le principal concerné qui
s'appelle Dominique Sopo c'est lui
pertinent
c'est pertinemment qu'il a effectivement
un passif ancien avec la ministre donc
on n'est pas dans quelque chose qui
n'est là sur le fond Marianne quand
Marlène Schiappa a été secrétaire d'État
chargé de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et qu'elle avait donc la
tutelle y compris sur les
discriminations et donc sujet qui occupe
de fait SOS Racisme tout ça est ancien
effectivement tout ça remonte de cette
époque et les principaux concernés le
savent pertinemment alors Laetitia dans
cette affaire on n'a pas beaucoup
entendu le gouvernement ni l'exécutif
c'était voulu ou c'était subite c’était
pensé c'était construit concerté évolue
et donc on a entendu ici et là quelques
ministres répondent quand même quand ils
étaient face à des questions dans les
interviews bon bah il répondait mais
c'était vraiment service minimum et
c'est normal la consigne avait été
donnée de ne surtout pas apporter de
l'eau à ce moulin qui était déjà bien
encombrant c'est simple j'ai échangé
avec un conseiller de de l'ombre en
communication du gouvernement il m'a dit
quand les faits sont accablants il n'y a
rien à faire à part attendre que ça
passe et donc c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé bah oui on voit que dans les
enquêtes d'opinion à Marlène Schiappa a
quand même perdu quelques points de
confiance c'est vrai mais si on regarde
les faits l'affaire Schiappa en
elle-même n'a pas été une onde de choc
pour le gouvernement l'exécutif
finalement a décidé de la laisser en
première ligne de ne surtout pas monter
pour la défendre et le pari c'était que
l'opinion publique allait se
désintéresser petit à petit de cette
histoire et puis se laisser happer par
une autre actualité c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec les émeutes urbaines quand on
regarde c'est le tout dernier baromètre
Ifop dans Paris Match on regarde dans la
conversation des Français cette affaire
Schiappa arrive en dernier juste après
les rumeurs de remaniement du
gouvernement donc les Français n'en ont
quasiment pas parlé je peux vous dire
que sur publicena.fr sur la plateforme
c'est ça fait partie des sujets les plus
les plus lus les plus regardés nous qui
avons un public féru de de d'histoire et
d'action parlementaire ça les a
passionnés est-ce que vous parliez de
remaniement est-ce que Marlène Schiappa
est menacé à son poste aujourd'hui
on a tous attendu qu'effectivement elle
remaniement ait lieu écoutez je regarde
encore une fois les faits en tout cas en
prévention on aurait pu imaginer qu'on
la sort du gouvernement parce que cette
affaire était vraiment trop
embarrassante non
l'exécutif et
imaginez
encore plus de lumière sur sur l'enquête
c'est-à-dire que sortir Marlène Schiappa
c'était mettre vous avez raison la
lumière sur cette affaire qu'on voulait
plutôt oublier et c'est vrai que pour
l'instant bon bah ça ça a quand même
fonctionné
dans les prochains jours s'il y a un
remaniement ça je ne sais pas seul
Emmanuel Macron et Elizabeth borne le
savent ils se sont vu ce matin peut-être
qu'ils ont déjà une petite idée mais on
n'en sait rien mais du côté du
gouvernement en tout cas ce qui se dit
c'est que factuellement
l'image de l'exécutif n'a pas été
entachée par cette histoire la cote de
confiance non plus et ce sont les seuls
faits qui sont retenus pour le moment
par le château merci beaucoup Laetitia
jangari on imagine quand même mal
Emmanuel Macron conservé Marlène
Schiappa dans un futur gouvernement
encadrement oui je pense que ce serait
une
scène décision que que au moins voilà
une forme de responsabilité politique en
matière qu'elle ne retrouve pas un poste
dans le futur gouvernement et j'imagine
que par rapport à ce qu'on fait moi je
suis pas dans le secret dire mais ce
qu'on voit de d'Elisabeth borne qui est
plutôt une image d'intégrité je suis pas
sûr que ce type de d'exercice de la
politique par la com soit véritablement
sa tasse de thé alors je sais pas si
Elizabeth va rester si mais dans
l'hypothèse où il y a un remaniement
sous la tutelle d'Élisabeth borne je
pense que ce serait de de bon aloi de de
laisser Marlène Schiappa de côté mais au
fond à mes yeux ça n'est pas l'essentiel
parce que à mes yeux ce qui est
intéressant c'est d'avoir une discussion
un questionnement
évidemment sur la question du
séparatisme etc mais sur la question de
la manière dont on exerce des
responsabilités gouvernementales sur ce
qu'est le principe de cette
responsabilité
d'intégrité aussi par rapport au choix
qui sont faits voilà c'est des problèmes
ce sont des problèmes de fond et c'est
pour ça que c'était très important que
qu'interviennent cette condition je suis
d'accord avec vous et la commission
d'enquête sénatoriale a fait son travail
à bien fait son travail mais elle est
une Salvi est-ce que quand même on est
dans une démocratie qui qui pratique la
procrastination c'est à dire quand il y
a une affaire on voit rarement un
ministre en exercice démissionné
contrairement à d'autres démocraties par
exemple du nord de l'Europe qu'on donne
souvent un exemple mais mais est-ce que
ça n'abîme pas finalement aussi le lien
des Français avec la classe politique en
général mais je le crois vraiment et par
ailleurs on est depuis six ans
maintenant avec un président de la
République donc je rappelle quand même
qu'il a été élu dans des circonstances
très particulières qui étaient celle de
l'affaire François Fillon qu'il avait
lui-même à l'époque était interrogée je
crois que c'était sur un JT en disant
que lui président de la République il
n'aurait pas dans son gouvernement des
personnes mises en examen aujourd'hui du
jour ce qu'on appelait la jurisprudence
Balladur que se passe-t-il exactement
aujourd'hui Marlène Schiappa est empêtré
dans une affaire mais jusqu'à
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas pénalement
poursuivie et elle a raison de le dire
il y a une enquête judiciaire qui est en
cours or on a un ministre de la Justice
je le rappelle qui est mis en examen on
a un ministre du Travail Olivier du soft
qui va avoir un procès à la fin de
l'année et toute une toute un entourage
en fait qui est inquiété sinon viser par
des enquêtes judiciaires c'est un sujet
en fait c'est un sujet de démocratie
c'est un sujet de transparence et c'est
un sujet de gestion politique mais alors
votre avis là-dessus avec Claude rénale
parce que on peut alors moi je vais
j'aime bien faire parfois les les deux
arguments on peut aussi dire que il faut
laisser la justice faire son travail et
et dans un temps de condamnation
médiatique ultra rapide à l'heure des
réseaux sociaux on va on va avoir du mal
à former un gouvernement vous voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est à dire que c'est
facile d'attaquer un adversaire
politique de le mettre en cause dans une
affaire si on est obligé de la
démissionner dans les 24 heures
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça je pense
que la commission d'enquête justement
évite elle est là pour ça elle évite ça
la justice on le sait elle a son temps
certes un procureurs peut aller assez
vite mais ensuite il faut aller devant
devant un juge bon avant que qu'un
jugement sur cette affaire éventuelle
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui je ne permets pas
de ça des conséquences judiciaires
éventuelles quoi que ce soit sur le
sujet mais en tout cas c'est toujours un
temps long et vous êtes dans le pardon
vous êtes un peu dans le temps
intermédiaire si je veux dire entre le
l'immédiatet médiatique et le temps long
judiciaire d'accord et il me semble que
on a fait sortir si je puis dire les
éléments réels de cette affaire est-ce
que est-ce que vous enfin quand même une
commission d'enquête parlementaire elle
a aussi un objectif ou une stratégie
politique sous-jacente quand même
pourquoi vous dites ça je sais pas parce
que la commission d'enquête parce qu'il
y a des commissions d'enquête qui
mettent en difficulté un gouvernement
quand on est dans l'opposition comme
comme Jean-François Husson ça tombe bien
est-ce que alors ça c'est assez curieux
parce que c'est quelque chose qui nous a
pas traverser l'esprit voyez c'est et de
manière générale quand on regarde des
commissions passées ou des façons de
faire passer on se retrouve pas du tout
là-dedans c'est pas c'est pas notre
sujet si j'osais même vous voyez
quand on regarde le débat sur la laïcité
c'est un débat on va retrouver
énormément de personnalités de gauche
historiquement voilà je suis un élu de
gauche donc est-ce que vous voyez est-ce
que c'est un sujet que j'ai traité en
comment dire en essayant de de protéger
une vision de de personnalité très
impliquées dans la vie laïque et qui
très souvent sont issus y compris même
de mon propre parti politique il y a
quelques années qui était dans ce parti
politique il y a quelques années non je
suis pas c'est pas le sujet allez votre
avis là-dessus Jean Gary non j'avais
cette cette crainte parce que
historiquement ça a pu arriver et et
j'avais même eu ce parfois ce sentiment
au moment de la commission d'enquête sur
l'affaire Benalla bien que je l'ai
trouvé aussi à bien des égards
exemplaires je me disais ça heureusement
qu'elle a eu lieu au Sénat parce que
parce que
j'avais été enterré donc
bienvenue et bravo à la commission
d'enquête Benalla j'avais trouvé parfois
que on frisait un tout petit peu le
règlement de compte politique mais
c'était finalement un jeu légitime dans
notre dans notre vie publique alors là
j'ai franchement trouvé par exemple dans
le discours aujourd'hui qui a été tenu
par Claude Reynal quand il a présenté le
rapport avec cetera qui avait une une
sorte de neutralité surplombante si vous
voulez qui qui le mettait vraiment
au-dessus de ces règlements de compte
politique je vais vous donner la parole
sur ce thème je vois que vous voulez la
prendre mais d'abord j'accueille Tam
traduit parce qu'on va on va faire un
flash-back justement bonsoir Tam
bienvenue à vous sur ces commissions
d'enquête qui se sont multipliées au
Sénat et qui ont marqué les esprits oui
vous en avez parlé il y a eu bien sûr la
commission Benalla en 2018 il y a eu la
commission d'enquête sur les cabinets de
conseils l'année dernière en pleine
campagne présidentielle et donc cette
année cette commission d'enquête sur le
fond Marianne voilà trois exemples parmi
d'autres de commission d'enquête du
Sénat qui ont été très suivis par les
médias et qui ont été très suivis par
les Français qui auraient pensé qu'un
jour hein voilà Philippe Bas Jean-Pierre
soeur président rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête Benalla deviendra
un jour les héros du forum jeux
vidéo.com car je vais vous montrer une
photo voilà une photo pépite que j'ai
retrouvé dans ma boîte mail et qui
présentait donc les sénateurs comme des
Chevaliers Jedi qui avait combattu le
côté obscur de la Force en l'occurrence
qui avait enquêté sur l'ex chargé de
mission de l'Elysée Alexandre Benalla
aujourd'hui
pour la joie de tout ça aujourd'hui
l'équivalent et bien c'est un nouveau
plus gros nom qui a gagné Marlène
Schiappa à l'issue de son audition
devant les sénateurs regardez ce passage
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas je ne suis
pas en mesure de vous je ne connais pas
les échanges qui ont pu avoir lieu sur
ce sujet voilà c'est surnom c'est donc
Marlène shepa à la suite de l'audition
de la ministre que l'on retrouve sur les
réseaux sociaux et même plus alors tout
cela bien sûr fais sourire reste
anecdotique mais ça montre que les
travaux du Sénat à ces occasions ont su
capter l'attention bien au-delà des murs
du palais de Luxembourg alors pourquoi
elles intéressent autant et on peut
regarder un peu coup d'oeil dans le
rétroviseur pour l'expliquer voilà les
commissions d'enquête sont un instrument
ancien mais elles ont progressivement
changé d'ampleur entre des moyens
d'investigation qui ont été renforcés
aussi la publicité des auditions c'est
un élément qui a été très important
dernièrement les auditions peuvent être
diffusées en direct par les médias sur
Public Sénat sur les chaînes d'infos
elles peuvent faire le buzz sur les
réseaux sociaux et celle du Sénat elles
ont marqué elles ont marqué par leur ton
qui est resté courtois mais avec des
questions qui ont su mettre les
personnes auditionner en difficulté
regardez par exemple cette audition du
cabinet mackenza l'an dernier contrôle a
été d'accompagner la DTP pour organiser
un séminaire qui était prévu par le
ministère en lien avec centre
d'organisation internationale pour
réfléchir à quelles étaient les grandes
tendances d'évolution de marché de des
évolutions du secteur de l'enseignement
quelles étaient les évolutions aussi
attendues de marché d'enseignant et à ce
titre qu'elle pouvait être les
réflexions autour du métier d'enseignant
voilà ma kinza qui a eu du mal à
s'expliquer sur une mission qui a été
facturée tout de même 500.000 euros pour
un colloque sur l'avenir du métier
d'enseignant qui finalement n'avait pas
eu lieu au-delà et bien ces trois
commissions d'enquête elles ont eu une
particularité elles ont été des moments
où les Sénats donc exercés sa mission de
contrôle du gouvernement et donc ce sont
des travaux de contrôle qui ont rimé
avec contre-pouvoir d'ailleurs les
relations ont été extrêmement tendues
avec l'exécutif vous l'avez rappelé pour
la commission d'enquête Benalla le
gouvernement dénonçait alors un coût
politique ce coup-ci ça n'a pas du tout
était le cas Marlène Schiappa a même dit
souhaiter cette commission d'enquête
regardez
la commission des finances dont le
sérieux et unanimement reconnu de
manière transpartisanale je me réjouis
qui se soit saisi de ce sujet voilà pour
les couleurs qu'elle vous lancez
exactement que le drainage avant la
Commission dans quête qui a finalement
conclu au fiasco du fond Marianne et les
attentes après son grand évidemment et
oui c'est sans doute l'une des
difficultés auxquelles les sénateurs de
cette commission d'enquête vont être
confrontés après l'affaire Benalla par
exemple les sénateurs transmettent leur
rapport à la justice qui finit par
classer sans suite les poursuites pour
faux témoignage des collaborateurs
d'Emmanuel Macron attention donc à
l'effet deceptif sur l'opinion si les
conclusions d'une commission d'enquête
ne sont pas suffisamment suivies des
faits merci Tam pour toutes ces
informations Allianz avis c'est
effectivement une question ça les suites
judiciaire d'une commission d'enquête
qu'est-ce que vous en dites oui c'est
c'est une question en l'occurrence
simplement je voulais dés revenir
là-dessus parce que je trouve que c'est
un une vraie question qui est à mon avis
celle qui nous occupe tous aujourd'hui
une commission d'enquête sénatoriale
c'est pas un jeu politique en fait c'est
un principe fondamental qui est celui de
la séparation des pouvoirs il faut que
le pouvoir arrête le pouvoir mais ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir des arrières
pensées politiques parfois je dis pas
que c'était le cas pour cette commission
d'enquête mais ça n'empêche pas d'avoir
des arrières pensées politiques comme ça
ces pensées justement contre nos
principes fondamentaux c'est à dire que
c'est important on a trop oublié
aujourd'hui qu'on était aussi dans une
démocratie parlementaire qui doit
exercer une mission de contrôle et
justement vous citiez la commission
d'enquête de l'Assemblée nationale au
moment de l'affaire Benalla c'est le
contre exemple parfait là on a un
problème politique parce que précisément
le Parlement ne peut pas exercer son
rôle de contrôle ceci étant dit je crois
que Monsieur Raynal et Monsieur Husson
ont fait un complément d'information à
l'article 40 donc qui a été déposé et
pour l'enquête qui est ouverte par
nationale financier je crois savoir mais
je pense qu'il vaut mieux l'interroger
lui que moi qu'il n'y a pas eu de
signalement pour parjure alors qu'on
sait quand même rendu compte qu'il y
avait effectivement des versions
contradictoires est-ce que vous pouvez
alors allez-y
vous êtes journaliste posez des
questions il y a aucun souci
non c'est très d'abord parce que
lorsqu'on est sur une accusation de
parjure on est sur quelque un élément de
droit très précis avec des éléments
qu'il faut fournir qui sont extrêmement
précis et en particulier il faut avoir
une disons plusieurs sources pour
pouvoir établir le parjure lorsque par
exemple vous avez deux analyses ou deux
positions qui sont développées l'une par
le préfet j'en ai l'autre par la
ministre ça nous permet pas en tant que
tel d'établir qui dit précisément la
vérité c'est-à-dire que il y a deux
hommes qui sont passés le préfet a
peut-être mal interprété bon avoir un
doute si vous voulez mais il faut quand
même assez précis pour dire l'un des
deux avant il faut voilà il faut avoir
des choses là où la ministrement qui
c'est pas sur des éléments de la
commission d'enquête ou justement tout a
été super bordé par l'avocat quoi qui a
dit attendez là vous n'y allez pas là
vous répondez pas et ça a été un jeu de
contournement des questions là où elle a
vraiment menti c'est quand elle est
venue sur ce plateau vous auriez pu
montrer l'image sur le plateau ici de
Public Sénat et qu'elle a et qu'elle a
dit et moi je me suis occupé de rien sur
la sélection des alors ça là c'est clair
c'est établi face au serment mais là
elle n'était pas sous serment et c'était
c'est donc à la mais de manière générale
faut oublier ça le le point qui est
important c'est est-ce que la mission
d'enquête a été empêché de trouver le
point d'arrivée c'est-à-dire le point
d'équilibre et le point de vérité la
réponse est non nous y sommes arrivés
voilà et évidemment on sait pas beaucoup
appuyé sur les déclarations de la
ministre qui nous en a fait très peu
donc comme ça fait très peu il a fallu
les trouver ailleurs mais nous les avons
trouvé donc à partir de là le sujet si
vous voulez il est il dépasse ça et je
voudrais si vous permettez en un mot
dire ce qui me paraît essentiel ce qui
me paraît
dérisoire ce qui me paraît essentiel
c'est que on a dans notre société et
dans notre manière de diriger des
événements et juste derrière des
événements le rôle des cabinets
aujourd'hui c'est de trouver des
contre-infos donc vous avez un événement
il faut tout de suite trouver une
réponse et donc ça amène à des
dysfonctionnements complets alors vous
avez des choses qu'on ne dit plus projet
de loi immédiat encore que le Président
de la République sur les émeutes tout de
suite projet de loi bon vous voyez tout
ça c'est pas bon et quand on est dans
cette façon de faire on privilégie à ce
moment-là le coût de corps parce que ça
permet de de dépasser l'é
au fond après tout le coup de com
pourquoi pas à condition qu'il soit
suivi d'une justement ça pose la
question de de ce combat contre les
séparatismes on peut considérer que
évidemment ça méritait mieux que cette
affaire on écoute là-dessus un autre
extrait de la conférence de presse de
cet après-midi avec toujours
Jean-François Husson les montants sont
élevés et beaucoup d'associations
dans la beaucoup entendu les uns les
autres dans nos territoires sont
révulsés à la fois sur la manière la
légèreté avec laquelle tout ces dossiers
ont été suivis les versements réalisés
l'absence de contrôle globalement une
seule personne pour suivre un dossier
majeur d'une telle ampleur alors
que
ce vecteur nous paraît de voir être
regardé avec beaucoup d'attention en
tous les cas la lutte contre les
discours séparatistes c'est peut-être
une des conclusions mais hors commission
d'enquête mérite me semble-t-il
d'être mené avec une autre envergure une
autre ambition j'engarie que c'est un
élément très important on va conclure ce
débat là-dessus pourquoi ça vous semble
essentiel ah oui à mon sens c'est un des
éléments très très importants puisque on
définit un objectif qui je pense est un
objectif que chacun d'entre nous ne peut
partager il suffit d'aller un petit peu
sur les réseaux sociaux pour voir à quel
point il y a un poison de de ce discours
séparatiste islamiste tout ce que vous
voudrez ou d'extrême droite enfin je
vais participer personnellement à une
commission sur bénévole
à la demande du Président de la
République on était plusieurs historiens
politologue etc
sur les lumières à l'air du numérique on
essayait de préconiser des solutions
pour
essayer de combattre justement cette
désinformation ce complotisme etc donc
il y a quelque chose là il y a un enjeu
qui est très important on connaît la
force des réseaux sociaux et
effectivement et c'est à l'honneur de
cette commission d'avoir pointé
l'importance de ce combat et comment
dirais-je un regard de cette importance
malheureusement ce qui s'est ce que ça a
donné sur le plan de la décision
publique parce que il y a effectivement
beaucoup de bonnes volonté des
associations y compris dans les dans les
17 là il y en a qui font vraiment du bon
travail et qui ont été quelque part
comment dire salis par la manière dont
les choses se sont produites donc il
faudrait pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du
bas et rappeler que derrière ça il y a
un objectif qui je pense réunir ensemble
tous ceux qui ont certaines idées de la
République et qui est justement de
combattre ce séparatisme
je pense que on partage tous l'idée que
effectivement il y a des discours qui ne
sont pas acceptables et sur les réseaux
sociaux mais même ailleurs je veux dire
y compris politiquement on l'a vu ces
derniers jours y compris au Sénat il y a
des il y a des il y a des mots qui ne
sont pas acceptables aujourd'hui dans
notre République et c'est un combat je
pense que que nous partageons tous
quelle que soit nos idées maintenant
c'est vrai ce qui a permis de révéler
cette commission d'enquête c'est
d'ailleurs ce sont les mots de Monsieur
Husson c'est la désinvolture et je
trouve que c'est ça en fait qui est le
plus prégnant dans tout ce qu'on a pu
observer ces dernières semaines c'est un
c'est je crois que c'était écrit dans le
rapport d'ailleurs c'est une forme
d'amateurisme de désinvolture qui
clairement n'est pas à la hauteur il me
semble comme ça qu'on vous écoute tout à
l'heure on a commencé l'émission vous
nous parliez de scandale de scandale
d'affaires d'État et puis là on finit
sur la description
essentiel derrière tout ça c'est d'une
part à quel point c'est important
d'aller dans cette ce combat contre le
séparatisme et à quel point c'est
important d'avoir ce contre-pouvoir
parlementaire nous sommes dans une
démocratie représentative je pense
qu'elle a besoin de dans son
fonctionnement de revenir à son principe
d'un régime parlementaire car nous
sommes un régime parlementaire et cette
commission elle a montré à quel point
c'était important d'amener du
contre-pouvoir quand il y a des dérives
de l'exécutif simplement pour répondre
la désinvolture ou la maturisme devient
un scandale quand il s'agit en fait d'un
événement aussi grave je rappelle quand
même que ce front est lancé après
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty qui a créé
en France un émois terrible et en fait
le gâchis aujourd'hui dont parle les
sénateurs c'est précisément celui-ci
donc c'est un scandale à vous le mot de
la conclusion sur ce combat qui méritait
tellement mieux que que ce scandale de
la fondation du fond Marianne pardon
il faut continuer de le mener ce combat
bah évidemment qu'il faut continuer à et
il faut le mener dans des bonnes
conditions et ces bonnes conditions
elles sont souvent faites de discrétion
de travail sur le terrain de travail de
fourmis et c'est pas par des grandes
envolées que l'on gagne ce combat c'est
un travail de terrain mené par des
associations qui le font depuis des
années et qui le font dans de très
bonnes conditions pour la plupart
d'entre elles donc je crois qu'il faut
le mener et puis tout de même
effectivement
quel ironie que l'ironie de d'avoir un
projet dont une des idées fortes c'est
de renforcer les valeurs de la
République et au final de donner une
image de la République faible
oubliant c'est de voir ne transmettant
pas je rappelle que
l'équipe l'équipe ne transmet rien un an
après la création du fond
la ministre n'est plus ministre elle est
remplacée par une équipe qui arrive de
mois après dans le dossier c'est le
dossier ministre et qui est transmis il
n'y a pas une information sur le fond
Marianne personne est au courant du fond
Marianne à ce moment-là le fond Marianne
n'existe plus on s'est servi
involontairement sans doute avec la
volonté de bien faire je ne pourra pas
j'aurais pas mettre des mots trop durs
mais on s'est servi d'un événement
dramatique pour
afficher une politique publique via la
communication et ça se termine dans
l'oubli le plus total et moi je pense
que la ministre a minima doit des
excuses à la famille du professeur
assassiné merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci Claude Raynal
merci évidemment l'insalub et Jean Gary
que je rappelle le titre de votre livre
lisé contre Matignon le couple infernal
qui est publié aux éditions taland